Candid Truth
Hello everybody. Welcome back to Candid
Truth
where the truth is not an option but the
standard. So, as Mikey has said in the
chat, I dug up a bunch of things on
Christmas
and I hope you guys are um
ready to buckle up and get through it.
It's um
more than I thought I would find. So,
without further ado,
let's begin.
Okay.
So, the truth behind Christmas.
This gives us a little bit of a sneak
peek already.
Okay. So, let's begin with the
mythologies that actually
um are traces of where it came from,
where Santa and some of the practices
came from.
Number one, in the Greek, it is from
good God Cronus with a K or Cronus with
a C
and a festival of Chronia.
In the Roman, it is God Saturn and the
festival of Saturnalia.
In Athens, it was Apollo with his
festival of Pyanopsia.
In
European and British amalgamations, we
have the God Woden and the father and
Father Christmas or Saint Nicholas,
Krampus and Sinterklaas.
All right.
So, let's dig in. Let's read a little
bit about what each of these has to do
with it.
All right.
The ancient Athenian festival of Chronia
used to take place on the 12th day of
Hecatomb-
aeon.
The first month of the Attic calendar.
It coincided with the middle of summer
and honored the father God Cronus,
considered a patron of the harvest.
Although it was celebrated in the
summer, it was a major influence on the
most popular Roman festival,
the famous Saturnalia,
dedicated to Saturn,
Cronus's Roman equivalent.
The festival of Saturnalia was initially
celebrated
on the 17th of December,
but was later extended to three and
eventually to seven days until the 23rd
of December.
Instead of harvest time, the Roman
version of the celebration was in fact
linked with the winter sowing season.
The Athenian Chronia was a public
holiday which only lasted one day,
but was even observed by slaves,
who would sit on the same table
at the same table as their masters to
enjoy the fruit of their hands
hard labor.
It also included offerings, especially
of fruit and bread.
The Saturnalia was also a public holiday
associated with merry drinking
and exchanging of small gifts such as
candles, wax models of fruit and waxen
statuettes.
In this case, too, the slaves were
spared from their usual tasks and took
part in their lively feast.
People would also decorate their homes
with evergreen boughs and sprigs of
mistletoe,
a symbol of eternal life, but also love
and peace.
Many considered the custom a predecessor
of Christmas wreaths,
mistletoe decoration and even the
tradition of the Christmas tree.
Also, according to some sources, a mock
king or Saturnalic Saturnali- itious
priest princeps, wow,
was customarily chosen to preside for
several days over the festivities.
This custom is believed to be the origin
of the tradition of the king cake
served on the day of the Epiphany in
France and some Spanish and
German-speaking countries.
The cake, usually made of some sort of
sweet dough
or puff pastry,
has a small figurine hidden inside it.
The person who finds it
in his or her piece of cake is offered
some kind of prize
and many or and may be crowned with a
purple coronet
or crown, I think.
Okay.
Pyanopsia, the festival for
Apollo, which was held in Athens,
the God of light, healing and music.
It was It is in the month of Pyanepsion
or October or and November,
which actually was named after the
festival. Hm.
Pyanopsia means beans stewing
in reference to the sacred offering of a
rich pulse stew
to the temple of Apollo
to honor the autumn harvest.
People also thank the God with with the
offering of
the Eiresione.
Eiresione, okay. A branch of olive or
laurel bound with purple or white wool
and adorned with fresh fruit and small
pastries made with honey, oil and wine.
The branch was drizzled with wine and
carried in procession by a chanting boy
to the temple of Apollo,
where it was suspended at the gate.
According to some sources, the donor
Sorry, the doors of of houses were
similarly decorated.
This, too, is considered a predecessor
of Christmas decorations.
Okay. You hanging in there with me?
Let's continue to the point where we're
getting with Santa Claus.
So, perhaps the figure most associated
with Christmas folklore worldwide is
that of Santa Claus.
The modern portrayal of the Santa as a
merry white-bearded man carrying gifts
for children is based on a amalgamal
I'm sorry, amalgam of several different,
mainly European, traditions. Drawing
from the British figure of Father
Christmas and the Germanic deity Woden.
Above all,
however, he seems
related to the historical figure of
Saint Nicholas
as attested by his name. Santa Claus is
a phonetic derivation of the Dutch
Sinterklaas,
Sinterklaas, maybe,
meaning Saint Nicholas.
All right.
The actual Saint Nicholas of Myra
in 270 to 343 was an early Christian
bishop of Greek descent from the city of
Myra in Asia Minor
during the time of the Roman Empire.
He was also known as Nicholas
the Wonder Worker,
as he was believed to have performed
many miracles.
He is venerated in many countries as a
patron saint of sailors, merchants,
repentant thieves, children and students
among else.
Many legends regarding him show him
helping the poor and needy, especially
through secret gift-giving.
If you ever wondered where somewhat of
the white elephant gift-giving and
exchanges came from,
now you know.
This also ties back, just in case
anyone's wondering, to Saturnalia,
where they did that as well.
Okay. Back to what I was reading, the
first paragraph, second sent- second to
last sentence.
According to one of the most famous
stories about him,
he once rescued three girls from forced
prostitution
by dropping a sack of gold
a gold coins
through the window of their house each
night for three nights so their father
could pay their dowries.
In Greek tradition, the figure of the
gift-bearing bearded man old man is
identified as Saint Basil
instead of Saint Nicholas.
He is thus believed to bring gifts on
New Year's Day, which in Greece is also
Saint Basil's feast day.
Basil of
Is that Caesarea?
Also called Saint Basil the Great
in 330 to 379 was a famous and
influential theologian
and the bishop of Caesarea
Mazaca in
Asia Minor.
Basil was known for his generosity
towards the underprivileged. He
organized a soup kitchen and distributed
food to the poor during a famine
following a drought and he gave away his
personal family inheritance to benefit
the poor of his diocese.
On New Year's Day,
Greek families serve
the Vasilopita.
Ooh.
In tradition in a tradition very similar
to that of the king cake mentioned
above, now pita, of course, is the kind
of bread, the flatbread with the pockets
inside.
So, not that that's bad, I love those,
but it was some kind of pita bread that
they're talking about.
Its name is also reminiscent of the word
king, but is supposed to have been
have taken its name from Saint Basil.
In Greek, the name Vasilos,
which means royal or kingly.
Although it is called a pie or pita,
it consists of simple sweet bread,
usually a round shape.
A coin is hidden in the bread and is
believed that the person who finds it
will have good luck for that year.
Just like the custom of the king cake,
the Vasilopita
pita is also believed by some to
originate from the festival of Cronia
and its Roman equivalent Saturnalia.
Okay.
So, here's
all of these put together
um
contrasting one another is what we're
going to do here.
So, let's start with Saturn.
And I'm sorry, it's
a little bit hard to see.
Saturn, his role is being the Roman god
of agriculture, wealth, and time.
Okay?
His attributes
are depicted as a wise, older figure
bearing a sickle or a scythe symbolizing
time
and harvest.
His character is associated with
abundance, prosperity, and the golden
age,
a mythical time of peace and plenty.
However, the dark aspects of Saturn
emerge in his connection to human
sacrifices during Saturnalia.
Where am I? Okay.
The dual nature of him is a benevolent
provider, but also a devourer,
reflecting the consuming nature of time
and mortality.
His key festivals are Saturnalia, a time
of indulgence, role reversal, and sexual
freedom,
sacrifices, and no clothing.
In connection to others, Saturn shares
characteristics with the Greek Cronos,
but is generally less malevolent in
Roman interpretations. You'll see why.
He has a There's a big reason why.
Um but that will be seen in just a
minute.
Cronos,
his role was a titan
ruling during the mythological golden
age and associated with time and cycles
of destruction and renewal.
So, time
and the golden age, which is exactly
what Saturn had as well.
He's often depicted as a powerful and
fearsome figure wielding a sickle.
And
interesting, he can be seen in
Krampusnacht,
which we'll get there.
Um
So, Saturn also had a sickle or a
scythe.
Character,
he's known
for
Oops.
Okay.
He is known for having devoured his
children to prevent a prophecy that one
of them would overthrow him,
which was fulfilled
by Zeus.
He represents the destructive and
consuming force of time. It said the
same thing for Saturn, and that's
Since it said that, I'll go ahead and
kind of
let you in on the fact that Saturn did
the same thing. He was known for eating
his children.
As the mythology and the story goes
behind it,
I'm going to not tell that yet. We're
going to get to that soon.
But let's go back to Cronos and his key
differences from Saturn.
While both symbolize time and harvest,
Cronos is portrayed as a darker, more
violent figure
in myth, especially in his relationship
with his children, okay?
Apollo, his role was the god of the sun,
music, prophecy, healing, and archery in
both Greek and Roman mythology.
Attributes depicted as a youthful,
radiant figure with a lyre, a bow,
or the sun's rays.
Character, he embodies order, light, and
rationality,
often serving as a counterpoint to chaos
and darkness.
Protective and benevolent, but also
capable of wrath,
as seen in myths where he brings
plagues.
Um I'm seeing someone's asking is
Rebecca is asking, "Is that literal?"
I'm not sure what you mean, Rebecca.
Oh.
Yeah, we'll come to that. Um
Okay.
So, let's see here.
Symbolism, he represents enlightenment.
This is Apollo still. Symbolism,
enlightenment, culture, civilization,
standing in contrast to the darker and
more chaotic deities like Cronos or
Woden.
Key festivals associated with light and
renewal, his worship contrasts with the
indulgence and violence
of Saturnalia or Yule celebrations. So,
now they're mentioning Yule, which most
of you I'm sure has
have heard about.
But let's put that on the back burner as
well.
Woden,
his role
is Woden or Odin.
He's the chief deity in Norse mythology,
wisdom, war, poetry, and death.
He's depicted as an old man with one eye
lost for wisdom,
wearing a cloak and a wide-brimmed hat,
often carrying a spear.
So, they're always carrying something.
Character, he's known for his
relentlessness, uh relentless pursuit of
knowledge, often at great personal cost.
He has a dual nature, wise and
benevolent to his follow- followers, but
ruthless and vengeful in battle.
He represents wisdom, leadership, and
the mysteries of life and death. His
connection to this wild hunt,
the wild hunt, ties him to the Yule
season.
Connections to Saint Nicholas, Woden's
image as an older man leading the wild
hunt during Yule
influences influenced Santa Claus as a
bearded, cloaked figure figure riding a
sleigh.
Okay.
Interesting. So, Saint Nicholas, I hope
you guys are hanging in there.
And you can see the differences.
Okay, one last one here, Saint Nicholas.
Role, Saint Nicholas was a 4th-century
bishop of Myra known for his generosity
and miracles. We kind of already covered
that.
Um
He wears traditional
Sorry, I I skipped down to attributes.
And he wears traditional religious robes
holding a staff or sack of gifts. So,
here we're getting to what
the timeline is pretty much from Saturn
all the way to Saint Nicholas
of how it's transpired that we got a man
in red robes
holding
a sack of gifts and supposedly giving
gifts to children.
He embodies charity, compassion, and
Christian virtue,
contrasting with the indulgence and
punishment associated with other
figures.
He's known for anonymously giving gifts,
such as the legend of providing dowries
for the girls.
Symbolism, he represents selfish
self-
Oh.
Selflessness,
um kindness, and the spirit of giving.
His evolution into Santa Claus, well,
his image
merged with folklore figures like Woden
and Sinterklaas,
evolved evolved into the secular,
commercialized Santa Claus of today.
So,
we're going to get into that, too.
Um
I didn't have more room, so I had to
put these on separate slides.
But here's a picture of what these look
like. Saturn,
I hate to say it, but is so graphic that
they have pictures of him
eating his children. Cronos, the same
thing. They're both holding sickles.
Apollo is supposed to be
more
um
polite and cultured
and handsome and everything, but he
still represents pretty much the same
thing. Woden, that is his depiction,
the Norse mythology behind him and the
sun.
Saint Nicholas,
this is an actual picture, they say, of
Saint Nicholas in the top right, and
then at the bottom, that's how we got
Santa Claus.
All right, let's continue.
Krampus, in Alpine traditions, Krampus
accompanied Saint Nicholas,
representing the duality of reward and
punishment during the holiday season.
Now, I'm just going to clarify
um
really quick, Krampus did accompany
Santa Claus everywhere they went.
So,
you'll see that in a in a moment.
Um
Well, maybe maybe not cuz I didn't
include that, but they go together to
people's houses in different parts of
the world and when people dress up like
them,
one to give out rewards and the other
Krampus to actually um
punish the children.
So, let's get back to the slides.
Okay.
So, Krampus's horned appearance,
Krampus often is depicted with horns,
cloven hooves, chains,
resembles traditional imagery of Satan.
Now, I think it's interesting that they
mentioned
chains.
Why chains?
I'm I'm not coming up with an answer,
but
isn't it Satan that's going to wear
chains
in the end?
Anyway,
he is a traditional image
uh resembles traditional imagery of
Satan, a demonic figure from Alpine
traditions.
Punished children who misbehaved,
paralleling Sa- Saturn's darker aspects
of cruelty and control.
So, Satan and Santa, I know there's a
lot of uh speculation and pushback from
that idea, but let's get a little bit
deeper look take a deep look at it. The
anagrammatic similarity between Santa
and Satan
has been noted by critics.
Emphasizing the secular and
commercialized distortion of Christmas's
original intent.
The modern Santa Claus with his
supernatural abilities, omniscient like
he knows if you've been bad or good, and
he knows when you're awake,
and material focus parallels the
deceptions attributed to Satan
in diverting worship from God.
His role as a punitive figure, meaning
punishment,
alongside Saint Nicholas reflects the
blending of paganism and Christian saint
veneration.
Okay. So, this is Sinterklaas.
He's a traditional figure in Dutch and
Belgian folklore based on Saint
Nicholas.
I want you to take a look,
a pretty good look at what he's wearing
and what does he resemble?
To me,
if we go back to the slides,
he kind of looks like the Pope.
The hat, the fish kind of hat, the
staff,
the robes, but yet enough like Santa
Claus that the red is there in the robes
and the embellishments.
Just an observation again.
All right. So,
the first sentence there still, based on
Saint Nicholas, he's a 4th-century
bishop known for his generosity and care
for children, celebrated on December 5th
or Saint Nicholas's Eve in the
Netherlands and December 6th, which is
Saint Nicholas's Day in Belgium.
Sinterklaas arrives on a white horse
accompanied by helpers called Zwarte
Piet. I do not know if I'm saying that
right, but
Black Pete,
who assists in distributing gifts to
well-behaved children.
The name Santa Claus is derived from the
Dutch Sinterklaas.
His depiction as a bearded red-robed
figure influenced the modern Santa Claus
image.
Gift-giving, Sinterklaas's tradition of
leaving gifts in shoes laid out by
children evolved into the practice of
stock stocking stuffing
on Christmas Eve.
Stories of Sinterklaas reflect the
charitable acts of Saint Nicholas, like
secretly giving money to help
impoverished families.
Pagan elements, Sinterklaas's arrival on
a white horse and association with
seasonal festivities parallels Woden or
Odin in Norse mythology who led the Wild
Hunt during Yule.
Sinterklaas represents the blending of
Christian saint veneration with
pre-Christian or pagan, they should just
say, winter traditions forming the
foundation of today's Santa Claus.
Okay.
So, let's just go into this. Let's
Let's take a look at what Old Nick
means. This is from Merriam-Webster
Dictionary
and it just tells you right out the only
thing they're saying here
is it's used as a name of the devil.
Synonyms, Beelzebub, Lucifer, fiend,
devil, Satan, and serpent.
And I thought it was interesting to note
that it is actually
um considered this
since circa
1643.
That's a long time.
It's nothing new.
All right. So, let me go full screen,
give you guys a look at that.
And then we're going to continue on to
the next slide I have.
This is also proof from an old um
encyclopedia dictionary that also says
colloquially
colloquially, I don't know if I'm saying
that right now. Sounds weird to me.
But Old Nick means the devil.
All right.
So,
there is a large druid connection here.
And
it has a lot to do with druidism. So,
we'll just dive straight in.
The druids in ancient Celtic priestly
classes contribute significant
connections to the characters and
traditions of Christmas through their
practices and beliefs, particularly in
the context of tree worship,
seasonal rituals and the use of sacred
plants.
Their traditions align with many aspects
of Saturn, Cronus, Woden, Krampus, and
even Sinterklaas, reflecting how Celtic
paganism influenced the development of
modern Christmas.
Tree worship and sacred groves,
the druids revered trees, particularly
oak trees, as sacred.
Groves were often used for ceremonies,
including fertility rituals and
sacrifices.
This aligns with the tree worship
associated with Saturnalia,
oh sorry, Saturnalian and Yule
traditions and the modern Christmas
tree, a practice adapted from these
um pagan customs.
Saturn and Cronus, like the sacrifices
to Saturn, druids performed offerings
under sacred trees during solstice
rituals.
Woden, Woden's association with the
world tree,
Yggdrasil, I'm not sure if I said that
right either,
echoes the druidic reverence for trees
as cosmic connectors.
Okay. Modern Christmas tree, the druidic
practice of decorating and honoring
trees
influenced the later Christmas tree
tradition.
All right. Their seasonal solstice
celebrations look like this. The druids
celebrated the winter solstice called
Alban Arthuan
at a time of rebirth and renewal,
honoring the sun's return after the
longest night of the year.
They believed in the cyclical nature of
life and time, reflecting themes seen in
Saturnalia, Cronus's myth, and Yule.
Saturn or Cronus both represent the
cyclical nature of time and renewal
celebrated during solstice festivals.
Krampus,
he is the druidic acknowledgement of
light and darkness, which parallels the
duality of Krampus and Saint Nicholas,
symbolizing punishment and renewal.
Mistletoe and the sacred plants,
the druids considered mistletoe sacred,
believing it held magical properties for
protection, fertility, and renewal.
It was often harvested during solstice
ceremonies and used in blessings.
Mistletoe's significance ties directly
to its incorporation into Christmas as a
symbol of love and reconciliation.
Apollo, Apollo's association with
healing and enlightenment reflects the
druidic use of mistletoe for medicinal
and spiritual purposes.
Asaria, I will get to that in a minute,
why oak trees have significance for
druids
over any other tree.
Just a minute.
Saint Nicholas or Sinterklaas, the
tradition of blessing homes during
solstice rituals influenced Christian
practices of bringing sacred greenery
indoors,
mirrored in Sinterklaas's charitable
acts.
The druids emphasized the balance of
light and dark, aligning with solstice
as a turning point in the year.
Their so ceremonies often included fire,
candles, and other symbols of light to
honor the sun's rebirth, influencing the
use of candles and lights in Christmas.
Connections, Saturn and Cronus both
embody the shifting power of light and
dark forces during the year's cycle.
Krampus, his dark punishing role mirrors
the druids' acknowledgement
of darkness as part of life's balance.
The Wild Hunt and Woden,
such as seen in Yule,
in Celtic and German traditions,
the Wild Hunt was associated with the
solstice, led by a horned god or
powerful deity like Woden or Cernunnos
in Celtic lore.
The druids believed in spirits and
deities roaming the Earth during
solstice nights,
seeking offerings or punishing those who
dishonored the gods.
Woden or Odin, the Wild Hunt's and myth
imagery is influenced by Santa Claus's
sleigh and Krampus's fearsome roles.
Krampus,
the druids' acknowledgement of roaming
spirits aligns with Krampus's role as a
dark punishing figure.
Okay.
Oh my.
So, last one here is
gift-giving and offerings. Druids
offered gifts to deities and spirits
during solstice rituals to ensure
blessings for the coming year.
This practice evolved into the exchange
of gifts during Saturnalia and later
Christmas.
Saint Nicholas or Sinterklaas,
the connection there is the Christian
adaptation of gift-giving
echoes the druidic and Saturnalian
practice of presenting gifts and
offerings.
Krampus, the contrast of rewards and
punishments reflects the dual nature of
solstice offerings.
Blessings for the worthy and
consequences for the unworthy.
Druidic legend or legacy in Christmas.
The Druid's solstice traditions laid a
foundation for many aspects of
Christmas.
Influencing its symbols, characters, and
customs. Trees and greenery because
Christmas trees, mistletoe, and wreaths
link back to Druidic tree worship and
sacred plants.
Light and darkness such as candles,
Krampus versus Saint Nicholas reflect
their solstice emphasis.
Spirits and wild hunt imagery inspired
by Krampus and Santa Claus narratives.
So, through Christianization, Druidic
practices were repurposed to fit the new
holiday framework blending Celtic
spirituality with Roman and Norse
traditions to create the Christmas we
recognize today.
All right, I'm going to just go back
real quick
and
um actually, I'll just continue.
So, these are illustrations of Krampus.
Gruss vom Krampus, like it says on most
of these pictures,
actually means
welcome
or hail Krampus.
So, in this you can see that he's
obviously torturing and punishing,
scaring many children and chaining them
up behind him.
Packing them into baskets, all this is
happening.
This is a video
about how it actually looks
when they do these festivals.
Okay, so yes, it is scarier than
Halloween.
Um most of the time they don't have
those fences up that you see and they
actually can grab you if they want to
and drag you through the streets a bit,
scare people further. They usually do
that to children.
Um
and I saw other videos of that, but I
didn't really want to include it.
And I heard someone ask about the
wreath. Now, the wreath has everything
to do with
this tree worship.
Because what you have is
what I heard from some uh pagan
video that I found was that you have
half of the year dedicated to the oak
king
and the other half dedicated to the
holly king.
So, during those times, we are
usually making a wreath especially out
of holly
for Christmas.
And that only worship is ha worships
that tree, that kind of tree worship.
And it does have that circular um look,
so it does have everything to do with
wanting the sun to come back to signify
that you are trusting in that god, the
sun god, to come back
in the spring.
So, that should take care of that um
Now, the Druids liked the oak trees
because
they
naturally grew holly within them or
mistletoe, I'm sorry. Mistletoe.
And so, they kind of had everything in
there at once. It was a medicinal use
for holly
holly. They used it for their sacre
sacred plant type rituals.
It all was in one and when you are a
Druid, you are actually one who knows
the oaks. They're supposed to be your
oracles, the one where you get knowledge
and wisdom from
to know how to do everything. What to do
about situations, uh
divination, if you will, um
clairvoyance.
They worshiped the trees and they did.
They carried out many rituals um
by them or underneath them.
And so, um that's the connection there.
If there's more, I will point it out,
but just to clarify that point.
Okay.
So, let's get back to
um what I have next is a
page from this book.
It says, "Even where the sun was the
favorite object of worship, as in
Babylon itself and elsewhere,
at this festival he was worshipped not
merely as the orb of day,
but as God incarnate.
It was an essential principle of the
Babylonian system that the sun or Baal
was the one only God.
Did you hear that? The one and only God.
When therefore Tammuz was worshipped as
God incarnate, that implied also that he
was incarnate an incarnation of the sun.
In the Hindu
mythology, which is admitted to be
essentially Babylonian, this comes out
very distinctly.
There Surya or the sun is represented as
being incarnate.
The born for the purpose of subduing the
enemies of the gods
who without such a birth could not have
been subdued.
I'm not sure exactly what that last
sentence means, but this is where it all
began.
They also say, "It was no mere
astronomical festival then that the
pagans celebrated at the winter
solstice.
That festival at Rome was called the the
feast of Saturn.
And the mode in which it was celebrated
here showed whence it had been derived
derived.
The feast as regulated by Caligula
lasted five days. Loose reins were given
to drunkenness
and revelry. Slaves had a temporary
emancipation and used all manner of
freedoms with their masters. This was
precisely the way in which according to
Berosus, the drunken festival of the
month
Thebeth,
ha it's quite hard to say without
sounding like you have a lisp,
answering
to our December, in other words, the
festival of Bacchus was celebrated in
Babylon. So,
the festival of Bacchus in Babylon was
celebrated in December.
It was the custom, says he, during the
five days it lasted for masters to be in
subjection to their servants.
And one of them ruled the house clothed
in a purple garment like a king. So,
think of the king cake they were talking
about.
This purple robed servant was called
Zoganes, the man of sport and
wantonness,
and answered exactly to the lord of
misrule.
Interesting.
That in the dark ages was chosen in all
popish countries,
ooh, interesting to say popish, huh?
Popish countries to lead the revels of
Christmas.
The wassailing, I don't know how to say
that,
bowl of Christmas
had its precise counterpart in the
drunken festival
in the drunk a drunken festival of
Babylon and many of the other
observances still kept up among other
ourselves at Christmas came from the
very same quarter.
The candles
in some parts of England lighted on
Christmas Eve and used so long as the
festival season lasts were equally
lighted by the pagans on the eve of the
festival of the Babylonian god
to do honor to him. For it was one of
the distinguishing peculiarities of his
worship to have lighted wax candles on
his altars.
The Christmas tree, now so common among
us, was equally common in pagan Rome and
pagan Egypt.
Think of that.
Rome and Egypt. That's usually where you
go back to find a cult
things.
In Egypt, that tree was the palm tree.
In Rome, it was the fir.
Now, think back um whoever asked the
question about the wreaths, now is the
time to think about those wreaths
and what they may be m- made out of
depending on certain cultures and
backgrounds or different parts of the
year. They're telling you right now. In
Egypt, it was the palm tree. In Rome, it
was the fir tree. The palm tree denoted
the pagan Messiah as Baal-Tamar.
The fir tree You to him
was referred to him as Baalberith.
Berith.
The mother of Adonis, the sun god and
great
meditatorial divinity,
was mystically said to have been changed
into a tree.
And when in that state to have brought
forth her divine son.
So, interesting. She was a tree and then
she had a son
divinely.
If the mother was a tree, the son must
have been recognized as
the man, the branch. Interesting.
Hmm.
And this entirely accounts for the
putting of the Yule log. Oh, how it Here
we go.
For the putting of the Yule log into the
fire on Christmas Eve and the appearance
of the Christmas tree the next morning.
As Hero Ashta,
um the seed of the woman,
I know that's a god that's related to
some religion. I forgot which one.
The seed of the woman, which
which name also signified
Ignigena
or born of the fire,
he has to enter the fire on Mother
Night.
Okay, so think about this.
On Mother Night that he may be born the
next day out of it as the branch of God
or the tree that brings all divine gifts
to men.
But why, it may be asked, does he enter
the fire under the symbol of a log?
To understand this,
it must be remembered that the the
divine child born at the winter solstice
was born as a new incarnation of the
great god
after that god had been cut in pieces
on purpose to revenge his death upon his
murderers.
Okay, this actually ties back to several
different mythologies and goddesses and
gods.
But let's continue.
Now the great god cut off in the midst
of his power and glory was symbolized as
a huge tree
stripped of all its branches and cut
down almost to the ground.
But the great serpent, the symbol of the
life-restoring
use Asclepius,
twisted itself around the dead stalk.
And lo, at its side up sprouts a young
tree.
A tree of an entirely different kind
that is destined
that is destined never to be cut down by
hostile power.
Even the palm tree, the well-known
symbol of victory.
The Christmas tree, as has been stated,
was generally at Rome
a different tree, even the fir tree.
But the very same idea as was implied in
the the palm tree was implied in the
Christmas fir.
For that covertly symbolized the newborn
god as Baalberith.
I wanted you guys to see this. I know
it's a lot to read, but I wanted you to
see how it ties into what we've already
spoken about.
So, let's continue. Lord after
Baalberith, we have Lord of the covenant
is what it's called.
And thus shadowed forth the perpetuity
perpetuity and everlasting nature of his
power.
Now that after having fallen before his
enemies, he had arisen triumphant over
them all.
Therefore, the 25th of December, the day
that was observed at Rome as the day
when the victorious god reappeared on
Earth, was held at the Natalis
Invicti Solis,
the birthday of the unconquered sun.
I'm going to pause right there.
Does this sound familiar to anybody?
Where do we hear about the unconquerable
sun?
Anybody?
I know I'm kind of freestyling here, but
there's a huge connection.
When Constantine said that he became a
Christian,
that he saw
uh sign in heaven open up
like a cross
in the heavens,
it was indeed
he said that now
we have the venerable day of the sun. He
switched the day of worship, right?
It was now Sunday that he changed it to.
Why? For the
For What did I say?
For Invictus Solis.
So, who is that?
We really say it in history as Sol
Invictus,
the unconquerable sun god.
So, unless you didn't I mean, maybe you
knew that already, maybe you didn't.
But
that's where that comes from in history.
That direct connection.
So, we know it was actually for the sun
that he
was worshipping and also changed the
day.
Um Chad, good question about the layers
of paganism. I don't have time for that
tonight. This is only on Christmas. That
would take an entire session.
Okay, I just wanted to clear that up for
you guys.
Let's get back.
Okay.
So,
we're at the part where you see
the unconquered sun.
It says, "Now the Yule log is the dead
stalk." It's like mid
little more than halfway down.
Now the Yule log is a dead stalk of
Nimrod.
Okay, so it's telling you right away
where it came from.
Correlating to the other piece that said
it was from Nimrod,
which deified as a sun god but cut down
by his enemies.
The Christmas tree is Nimrod
redivivus, the slain god come to life
again.
In the light reflected by the above
statement on customs that still linger
among us, the origin of which has been
lost in the midst of
hoar antiquity,
let the reader look at the singular
practice still kept in the south of
Christmas Eve on Christmas Eve
of kissing under the mistletoe bough.
Okay?
Just a minute, we're going to get into
the mistletoe.
Thank you, Lisa Adventures. Yes.
It was very dark.
Um so, thank you for your prayers for
protection.
I seem to always dive into those topics,
but
it's always good. So, thank you very
much.
Um so, yes, the top of the next page on
the right,
that mistletoe bough in the Druidic
superstition,
which as we have seen was derived from
Babylon,
was represent representation of the
Messiah, the man, the branch.
The mistletoe was regarded as a divine
branch, a branch that came from heaven
and grew upon a tree that sprung out of
the earth.
Thus by the engrafting of the celestial
branch into the earthly tree,
heaven and earth that sin had that sin
had severed were joined together and
thus the mistletoe bough became the
token
of divine reconciliation to man.
The kiss being the well-known token of
pardon and reconciliation.
Excuse me for 1 minute.
Okay, sorry. Throat's a little bare. I
mean, parched.
But
so, let's go ahead and kind of flesh
this out a bit.
Ah.
It's kind of hard to connect the dots,
but
this connection between heaven and earth
and the tree coming down as an earthly
creation as a tree
actually has everything to do with what
is called
being reborn
in a ritual in the cult, which I've
covered before
in the Androgyny episode,
which is called becoming the
philosopher's stone.
The act of the
And
it is said that when you do that, you
are
I hate to say it in this way, but it's
almost like procreating.
That the moon and the sun somehow are
procreating and making a baby of a tree.
And they're kind of in on that in that
way, they're kissing and they're, you
know, body to body.
And that's the kind of ritual that they
usually do underneath that tree.
And so,
I don't know if that makes sense, but
um
I just want to say that there's that
connection. I hope that you If you don't
know what I'm talking about, go watch
that episode cuz it'll fill you in.
But they do indeed think that you can
actually be reborn under the sun and the
moon and the heavens
as a entity on Earth.
Most occult or pagan people definitely
believe that.
So, that is exactly what they're wanting
to accomplish during this time.
And the ceremony of kissing under the
mistletoe is letting the mistletoe do
its magic of making you
in connection with the heavens to do so.
Plus, it also is said to make you
fertile, so that whoever you're kissing
you'll probably
end up with that night. Um,
you might have children after that.
So,
let's get back to it again.
All right, so
let me see.
Okay.
And we're at the part where it says,
"Whence could such an idea have come?"
So, in other words, where did it come
from?
May it not have come from the 85th
Psalm,
verse 10 and 11,
which says, "Mercy and truth are met
together, religiousness and peace have
kissed each other.
Truth shall spring out of the earth
in consequence of the coming of the
promised savior.
The righteousness shall look down from
heaven. Certain it is that the Psalm was
written soon after the Babylonian
Babylon Babylonish captivity, and as
multitudes of the Jews after that event
still remained in Babylon under the
guidance of inspired men such as Daniel.
As a part of the divine word, it must
have been communicated to them
as well as to their kinsmen in
Palestine.
Babylon was at that time the center of
the civilized world, and thus paganism
corrupted symbol as it ever has done
had opportunities of sending forth its
debased counterfeit of the truth to all
the ends of the earth through the
mysteries that were affiliated with the
great central system in Babylon.
All right. Thus, the very customs of
Christmas still exist.
Oh, star sorry, still existent cast a
surprising light at once
on the revelations of grace made to all
the earth and the effort made by Satan
and his emissaries to materialize,
carnalize, and degrade them.
In many countries, the boar was
sacrificed to the god. Now, why do we
have like Christmas hams and stuff? This
is why.
Let me start again. In many countries,
the boar was sacrificed to the god for
the injury a boar was fabled to have
done to him.
According to the version of the story of
the death of Adonis or Tammuz, it was
as we have seen in consequence of a
wound from the tusk of a boar that he
died.
The Phrygian Attis, the beloved of
Cybele, whose story was identified with
that of Adonis, was fabled to have
perished
in like manner by the tusk of a boar.
Therefore, Diana, who through commonly
represented
though commonly represented in a popular
myth,
only as a huntress,
Diana was in reality the great mother of
the gods,
had frequently
had frequently the boar's head as her
accompaniment in token not of any mere
success in the case sorry, the chase,
but of her triumph over the grand enemy
of the idolatrous system
in which also she occupied so
conspicuous a place.
According to Diodorus Siculus, Venus
reconciled to the boar that killed
Adonis
because when brought in chains before
her, it pleaded
so pathetically that it had not killed
her husband
of malice
pre prepense,
but only through accident.
But yet in memory of the deed that the
mythic
mythic boar had done, many
done, sorry,
many a boar lost its head or was offered
in sacrifice to the offending
offended goddess.
In Smith,
Diana is represented with the boar's
head lying beside her on the top of a
heap of stones.
And in the accompanying woodcut,
in which the Roman emperor Trajan
is represented burning incense to the
same goddess,
there's a boar's boar's head which forms
a very prominent figure.
On Christmas Day, the Continental Saxons
offered a boar in sacrifice to the sun.
Okay.
Is that connection clear?
Cuz it it says it right there. The
Saxons took this even from their myths.
And they always have a boar sacrificed
to the sun on Christmas Day.
Okay?
All right.
So, let's see about it a little more.
All right. Down at the very bottom,
to propitiate her is why they did the
sacrifice for the loss of her beloved
Adonis. In Rome, a similar observance
had a evidently existed for a boar
formed the great article at the feast of
Saturn.
And as appears from the following words
of Martial,
"That boar will make you a good
Saturnalia."
So, that was the quote that they had
to say that you need to have a boar
to celebrate Saturnalia, which is the
Christmas time.
Hence, the boar's head is still a
standing dish,
interesting dish,
in England at the Christmas dinner, when
the reason of it is long since
forgotten.
Yet yes, the Christmas goose and Yule
cakes were essential articles in the
worship of the Babylonian Messiah
as that worship was practiced both in
Egypt and at Rome.
Wilkinson,
sorry,
Wilkinson in reference
reference to Egypt shows
that the favorite offering of Osiris
was a goose, and moreover that the goose
could not be eaten except in the depths
of winter.
As to Rome,
Juvenal Juvenal, I guess, says that
Osiris is offended.
Oh, sorry.
That Osiris, if offended, could be
pacified only by a large goose and a
thin cake.
Wow.
Oh my goodness, does that make anyone
else think hard?
I have heard
that when they have those wafers
that are round and blessed by the sun,
in most of the mythology, it's usually
said that those were the cakes that
Osiris needed to um
be reincarnated every day.
And so,
wafers taking the host in the Catholic
Church,
yes, God tells us to do communion, but
he never made it so that it was in the
shape of the sun, round, and stamped by
the Pope. Like, he never does that.
The Bible doesn't say that, but
there's a connection with Osiris and
her.
I guess Osiris needs that cake
to be able to
be pacified. And the goose.
So,
um
I don't know why the goose, except that
that was kind of one of his favorite, as
it shows right here. I'll just
I'll make it bigger.
You can see that
there is
a goose on his hat.
For whatever reason,
that was Osiris's emblem on his
um headdress.
So, yes, the wafer the priest gives you
is a wafer what I've heard is a wafer
for Osiris, cuz they're actually priests
of Osiris.
And it's not just Osiris, it's always
these different gods and goddesses
repackaged. It's pretty much the same
gods all the time. So, it's more than
Osiris. It's it's Cybele, the priest of
Cybele,
priest of all these other different
types of
god worship
or idol worship.
So, let's continue here.
Uh, it's hard to find where I was at
here.
Oh, yes, very at the very bottom here.
New paragraph. In many countries, we
have evidence of a sacred character
attached to the goose.
It is well known that the capital of
Rome was on one occasion saved when on
the point of being surprised by the
Gauls in the dead of night
by the cackling of the geese
sacred to Juno,
kept in the temple of Jupiter.
The accompanying
woodcut proves that the
goose in Asia Minor was a symbol of
Cupid,
just as it was a symbol of Seb in Egypt.
Wow, I never knew that. That's very
interesting.
In India, the goose occupied a similar
position, for in that land were read we
read of
sacred Brahmani geese
or geese sacred to Brahma.
Ah.
Does that surprise me, buddy?
I didn't know about that.
This was new to me about the goose.
And it's very interesting.
So,
I think that um
well, from what I know also, we might
get into that in a little deeper. Just a
minute.
Let's go back so everyone can see.
Um
actually, I need to go back one
to remind myself what I was going to
even mention here.
Okay, so the goose
the goose is that
which they are saying was kind of like
their alarm
their alarm system, their guard dogs in
the dead of night when the Gauls were
trying to attack. So, that helped them
out. They're sacred, they're
divine.
That's connection there.
All right, let's get back to seeing
this.
All right.
So, finally, the monuments of Babylon
show that the goose, this is at the very
top We're on the second uh sentence of
that paragraph. Finally, the monuments
of Babylon show the goose possessed a
like
mystic character in
Chaldea
which is Babylon.
And that it was offered in sacrifice
there as well as in Rome or Egypt. For
there, the priest is seen with the goose
in one hand
and his sacrificing knife in the other.
There can be no doubt then that the
pagan festival at the winter solstice,
in other words, Christmas
was held in honor of the birth of the
Babylonian Messiah.
The consideration of the next great
festival in the popish calendar gives
the very strongest confirmation
to what was now being said. That
festival called Lady Day is celebrated
at Rome on the 25th of March
in alleged commemoration of the
miraculous conception of our Lord in the
womb of the Virgin
on the day when the angel was sent to
announce to her the distinguished
uh honor
that was to be bestowed upon her as the
mother of the Messiah.
But who could tell when this
annunciation was made?
The scripture gives no clue at all in
regard to the time.
But it mattered not before our our Lord
was either conceived or born that very
day now set down in the popish calendar
is now annunciation of the Virgin and is
observed in pagan Rome in honor of
Cybele
the mother of the Babylonian Messiah.
Now, it is in manifest that the
it is manifest that Lady Day and
Christmas Day
Oh, wait. I guess that wasn't very
important.
Because I cut it off there, but let's go
back.
So, they're just saying that
um
the day in which Jesus really was born
or
was conceived is not written down. So,
why would they tell us to celebrate
something that he never told us to or
that never was even
recorded.
So, that in its connection has
everything to do with Cybele.
All right, so I hope that includes um or
covers
more about where they get a lot of this
stuff from Christmas.
But if not, we're going to dive deeper.
So,
um
just join me as we go along.
All right.
So, as
some of you might know or were hoping I
might get to.
If not, there are others who probably
didn't know that the Bible actually
talks about those who follow Nicholas.
They are called the Nicolaitans.
Or people call them Nicolaitans.
Um
anyway, there are no double T's in
there. So, I call them Nicolaitans.
And this is mentioned
several places in the Bible.
But we're just going to read
the um
article that I have on this.
So, it says, "What is the origin of the
Nicolae
Nicolaitans?"
In Revelation 2:6
and 15.
"Nicolaitan means a follower of
Nicholas. It comes from two Greek words
Nikos and
Lois or Los, um maybe.
Nikos means conqueror or destroyer.
And Laos means people.
So, could it be it's destroyer of the
people?
The original Nicholas was a conqueror or
destroyer of the people. Yes, okay.
Some people believe that the original
Nicholas was Nimrod.
The original arc rebel
who conquered the people
and found a man-made civil civilization
within two centuries after the flood.
This is actually cited in Genesis
10:8-12.
And while he was alive, Nimrod put
himself in the place of God. Or as a
biblical text puts it, he was a mighty
hunter before the Lord.
When he died
his admirers continued to worship him as
a divine hero. They called him Baal.
A name found throughout the Old
Testament meaning master or lord.
So, just a note on that, of course,
we're told never to worship Baal for
one.
Um when they mentioned a mighty hunter
before the Lord, I actually
break that down
in
um
Who is the Rain Man, I believe.
I cover where it started with Nimrod and
Baal worship
and um trace it back all the way back.
So, if you need to know about that and
don't quite understand how I got to
that, I have that source in that
episode.
All right.
Let's continue.
All right, Nimrod, that's the last
sorry, second to last paragraph at the
very bottom.
Nimrod also had other names.
One commonly used throughout Asia Minor
was Santa.
This is from
the Lempriere's
classical dictionary.
I may not have said that right.
But that
is where it's from. Santa Claus is not
or is but a shortened form of Santa
Santa Nicholas
or Saint Nicholas.
Many unknowingly honor this Nicholas
even in our day-to-day by observing
customs associated with December 25th.
Christmas originally was the Saturnalia
or birthday
of Nimrod.
Very true.
Of course, these customs handed down
from ancient paganism have been renamed
and made to appear innocent and good.
Others think that the Nicholas mentioned
in Revelation 2 is the man called
Nicholas
a proselyte from Antioch which is
ordained was ordained a deacon
a deacon early in the church's history
in Acts 6:1-6.
Writings of the time say that he later
came to follow gnostic teachings and
became an
ascetic.
And many followed his new doctrines.
Okay? So, when we revert back to
taking all this into account
let's then look at the very left in my
Bible verses that I have.
So, in Revelation 2:15-6
it says
"Likewise, you also have those who hold
the teachings of the Nicolaitans.
Repent therefore. Otherwise, I will soon
come to you
and will fight against them with the
sword of my mouth."
The next
verse I have is Revelation 2:6.
"But this thou hast
that thou hatest the deeds of the
Nicolaitans which I also hate."
Okay? So, just keep that in mind as we
go forward.
A little more on this.
The exact origin of the Nicolaitans is
unclear.
But Bible commentators believe that
there was a heretic sect who followed
the teachings of Nicholas
whose name means one who conquers the
people
who is possibly one of the deacons of
the early church mentioned in Acts 6:5.
It is possible that Nicholas became an
apostate
denying the true faith and became part
of a group holding the doctrine of
Balaam
who taught Israel to sin by eating and
sacrificing to idols and committing
sexual immorality.
That comes from Revelation 2:14.
Clement of Alexandria
says, "They abandoned themselves to
pleasure like goats
leading a life of self-indugence.
Their teaching perverted grace and
replaced liberty with license."
Okay?
Other commentators believe that these
Nicolaitans were not so called from
were not so called from any man, but
from the Greek word Nicola meaning let
us eat.
As they often encouraged each other to
eat things offered to idols.
Whichever theory is true, it is certain
that the deeds of the Nicolaitans were
an abomination to Christ.
They, like the Gnostics and other false
teachers, abused the doctrine of grace
and tried to induce licentiousness in
its place.
They give their sources there from the
Bible.
Okay, and it's now hitting me.
Who do we now have inventions made by
Elon Musk from?
Nikola Tesla.
That's where his original thoughts and
ideas for doing this
has come from.
Now, Nikola Tesla
I don't think he was I don't know. I
haven't looked into it, so I shouldn't
say, but I don't think he was originally
a bad guy. He's had pretty awesome
ideas.
I don't know where his thoughts were
coming from when he invented things.
But his inventions were pretty amazing.
But just that connection
Nikola Tesla and Nikola.
All right.
Let's continue.
Okay.
Down at the bottom um second paragraph
to the last Jesus commends the church of
Ephesus for hating the deeds of the
Nicolaitans as he does
in Revelation 2:6.
No doubt the leaders of the Ephesian
church protected their flock from these
destructive heresies and kept their
people from committing the same evil
deeds.
All sin is hateful to Christ and it
should be to his followers as we hate
men's evil deeds
not the men themselves.
For the church at Pergamos, Jesus
had not common
commendation
but censure.
Meaning that he could not recommend
them, but he had correction for them.
Unlike the Ephesians, they actually
embraced the teachings of the
Nicolaitans.
Uh Nicolae Yeah, okay. Nicolaitans.
Jesus warns them that unless they repent
they are in danger of the judgment that
is sure to fall on those who teach the
false doctrine
attack his church and destroy his
people.
This sort of judgment is poised over
their heads
and his patience is not limitless in
Revelation 2:16 and in 19:15.
The lesson for us is that the church of
the Lord Jesus throughout the ages has
been plagued by those of the Nicolaitan
spirit.
The only way to recognize false teaching
is to be intimately familiar with
the truth through the diligent study of
the word of God.
All right.
Before we get into that
let's go back
just a little bit on the Nicolaitans.
Um
what I further read
was that
they were people who truly they said
they were believers um such as Nicholas
originally was said to have been a
believer in Christ
and a part of the um
I guess apostles at one time.
But they actually always take
things out of context or add in
different pagan rituals to
um
to their beliefs.
And
I don't know about you
but
um
I guess where I'm going with this
is that we have a lot of people today
that are claiming to be Christians but
living just like this.
So
this kind of a uh
a message for our time that we need to
stop being like Nicolae Nicolaitans
or Nicolaitans
and mingling
paganism
with God's practices for our life.
They can't be married. They you cannot
have light and darkness and good and bad
together.
You need to be a pure salt of the earth
for God.
So that's my
my two cents on that.
Um as we get into the tree
so
the tree is a big topic.
Let's just read the first sentence. One
need not spend long hours in research to
find people throughout history have
incorporated trees into their religious
activities.
The tree being the largest of plants
readily lends itself to
majesty in the the worship Sorry, in the
worship of nature.
Sometimes the tree itself is worshipped.
Here's where we need to pay attention.
Please perk up.
Oh, sorry. Um I did say yes that God it
did hate the Nicolaitans. Indeed, he
did.
So, let's continue. The tree Oh,
sometimes the tree itself is worshipped.
Listen.
Listen closely. Other times the tree is
viewed as a conduit
to the god
a god or an object integral to their
religious operations.
Sometimes an altar is set up beneath a
tree or other times the tree is the
altar.
Does this make anyone else cringe?
Venerated trees are often called groves.
This is true whether one is speaking of
a group of trees or a single tree.
They just blew that cover cuz people go,
"Oh
they go, "You know, I only have one tree
in my house and that's only around
Christmas time."
And from what they're saying
even just one cut down in your in your
house
is called a grove
and is an altar.
So
there we go.
We will be getting to the gift part
and we'll see why that happens.
But let us continue.
In pagan rites, the grove is also is
often often Listen, often
a single tree.
And the grove can be in the forest among
other trees
or it can be moved indoors.
Okay.
Historically, groves were often
dedicated to one or more pagan gods.
That is true.
Offerings were either placed beneath the
grove like the Christmas custom of
placing presents beneath the tree
or were hung from the branches of a tree
like the Christmas custom of decorating
a tree.
Offerings must be intended for the
grove.
Okay, to the gods basically.
Or the pagan god associated with the
grove.
All right. So, there really is
coming from a pagan standpoint
you have a grove. You have a tree in
your house. You can't get any You can't
get around that that you actually are
you have an altar in your house
and offerings of gifts underneath that
tree or on that tree
that are meant for the grove and the
gods associated with the grove.
Let's continue.
As it says in the second paragraph to
the last
the ancient Assyrians had their sacred
trees which they purified by sprinkling
with a mil a lu
Well, man, I can't say that. mululu or
pine cone
which had been dipped into a sacred
bucket
called a ben
Man goodness, ben
dudu
as depicted in the image of the relief
here.
That was there in the original
um
article by God made us.
So
I'm not sure what relief they are
mentioning. But the relief in this image
is dated to the reign of Ashur
nasirpal the second who ruled from 883
to 859.
That relief is a direct physical
evidence that trees were decorated and
included in religious rites nearly a
thousand years before the birth of our
Lord and savior which directly
contradicts any notion that the
Christmas tree was developed for the
celebration of Christ's birth.
This relief also shows the religious
operations involving a tree with leaves
or needles refuting the popular
assertion that pagan practices only
involve the use of a bare stick or
maypole.
This relief was made within about 250
years of when Jeremiah penned his
description of groves in
Jeremiah verse chapter 10.
We will get to that in just a minute.
It gives us an image to go with
Jeremiah's description.
Some of the world's oldest and most read
texts also mention the groves from which
the Christmas tree gets its roots.
Homer's Iliad is thought to have been
written somewhere around 1200 BC.
In it, Homer reveals one of the most
familiar descriptions of ancients
worshipping at altars beneath the tree.
So, as for that
um verse in Jeremiah 10:3-4,
it says,
"For the customs of the people are vain.
For one cutteth a tree out of the
forest, the work of the hands of the
workman
with the axe.
They deck it with silver and gold, and
they fasten it with nails and hammers
that it move not."
Okay?
So, we're clearly not supposed to do
this as the customs of the people. Which
people?
Well,
the customs of the pagan people that God
always warns us not to follow.
All right?
This is a lot I Let me
Let me get closer.
This is a lot, but we need to understand
where this comes from and that there is
a connection. There's links between all
of these different stories and gods.
Start at the top. In that box, it says,
"We are sacrificing to the immortals in
hecatombs
without blemish upon the holy altars
about a spring
beneath a fair plane tree whence
flowered the sparkling water.
Then appeared a great sign, a serpent
bloody-backed, horrible, whom the
Olympian himself sent forth to light.
Glided
from beneath the altar and darted to the
plane tree."
This is in the Homer and Iliad Homer
uh page 26.
And it says, "Herodotus, who wrote this
in the 5th century BC,
tells of Xerxes being so enamored with a
tree
that he decorated it with gold ornaments
and left one of his elite guards to care
for it."
Now, when it says Olympians, we we
pretty much should know that that is for
the god Apollo.
All right?
Next box.
"Xerxes, who chose this way,
found here a plane tree so beautiful
that he present presented it with gold
ornaments and put it under the care of
one of his immortals." So, here we go.
We have it again.
That's exactly what Herodotus wrote.
"Decorating trees is a common element in
ancient writings." It says underneath
it. "The tree has throughout history
been so interwoven into the tapestry of
paganism
one may often have trouble discerning
where reality ends and myth begins, as
shown in the following quote, where the
golden fleece from a ram sacrificed to
Zeus
is nailed to a tree in a grove dedicated
to a god a pagan god Ares."
Okay, last
box there.
Uh, this Phrixus
"And Phrixus sacrificed the ram with the
golden fleece to Zeus, the god of
escape.
And the fleece he gave to Aeetes, who
nailed it on an oak in a grove of Ares."
There you go with the oak trees again.
And then it says, "Virgil also wrote
about tree worship. Here he reveals that
some trees were sacred to Jove or
Jupiter.
And that Greeks believed oak trees were
oracles."
All right, so they're going to explain a
little bit like I just did about oak
trees.
Next one. "A class springs from seed
that has dropped on the ground as tall
chestnuts and the giant of the woods,
the mast tree
that bears foliage sacred to Jove and
oaks revered as oracles by Greece. These
methods
nature first ordained
but then blooms every kind.
By them blooms every kind of forest tree
and shrubs in hollowed groves."
Interesting they said hollowed as we
have Halloween.
Hallows' Eve really is what it was.
But those groves themselves were
made holy basically, sacred.
So, Virgil died before Christ was born,
which again shows pagan rituals
involving trees and groves, which
predate
any use of a tree
in worshipping Christ.
The practice of worshipping in groves
has historically taken place at all
times of the year.
However,
December and more broadly the winter has
always been a favorite time
to connect religious operations with
evergreen trees.
It's all the tree worship.
Because the evergreens were seen to have
power
over the dark days of winter
since they retain their color and their
leaves throughout the year."
All right, last one in the
"Fanalia celebrated on the nones of
December in honor of Faunus
they sacrificed he-goats and made
libations of wine.
Their place of meeting for that purpose
was in the heart of the woods."
In chapter 14 of this writing,
"The pine tree was shown to be sacred to
the cult of Cybele.
Pine tree is one of Cybele's trademark
items.
Also, the Dendrophoria
was shown to be a ceremony connecting
connected with sacrifices to the pagan
god
which involved worshippers carrying
trees through the streets.
These rituals also involved wrapping the
base." Here we go. This is why we wrap
the base.
"Wrapping the base of the sacred tree in
wool similar to the practice of using
Christmas tree skirts today."
From Cybele.
All right.
Continuing.
"Arnobius makes mention of that
performed in the sacrifice of Cybele
consisting in carrying a pine through
the city and afterwards planting it
in memory of the pine under which Attis,
the favorite of the goddess, is said to
have been mutilated.
The branches of this tree they crowned
in memory of Cybele during the doing the
same and they covered its trunk with
wool.
Cybele having so covered the bosom
of Attis.
The persons by whom the tree was carried
were called
Dendrophori."
So,
underneath that,
we see chapter 11 showed how the oscilla
or masks used at the Saturnalia
were connected to medicine masks, which
were believed to be a conduit to the
blessing or healing abilities of a
sacred tree from which the masks were
carved.
These masks were also known to be to
likely be a replacement for human
sacrifices.
As already shown, tree worship is not
limited only to the cults of Cybele.
The following quote reveals the Celts
also used trees as idols to represent
their gods.
Um, middle box. "The incarnate god was
probably representative of a god or
spirit of earth, growth, or vegetation
represented also by a tree."
"Trees were integral in Celtic religious
operations. The learned class of the
Celts, which were called priests or
sorry, which acted as priests, teachers,
and judges were known as Druids which
literally translates to knowing the oak.
Druid.
According to MacCulloch,
Druids claimed superiority to kings and
called themselves creators of the
universe.
Modern-day Druids, like their ancient
predecessors, share a religious affinity
for all things nature.
However, their pagan practices are
thankfully void of the extreme nature of
the pagan ceremonies practiced by their
forefathers
which, as described in the following
quote by MacCulloch down below, says
That's what I have the circle around. It
says, "The Celts made their sacred
places in dark groves.
The trees being hung with offerings
and their kind of offerings, it says,
are the heads of victims.
Human sacrifices were hung or impaled on
trees
by the warriors of Boudica
Boudica, I guess.
These, like the offerings still placed
by the folk on sacred trees,
were attached to them because the trees
were the abode of spirits
or divinities,
who in many cases had power over
vegetation."
And it says below that, "One needs
little imagination to see the link
between modern-day Christmas tree balls
Here we go.
I know that Mikey was mentioning this,
but Christmas tree balls and ornaments
hung on Christmas trees today
and the human heads which the Druids
hung on their trees so long ago.
While the practices have become tamer
over time,
the origin of the practice is born out
of human sacrifice which relates
directly to why the Bible tells us not
to worship God in the same manner the
pagans worship their gods."
All right. So, that is probably the
possibly one of the deepest
uh,
darkest things about Christmas is why we
we decorate the tree in that way.
And then, of course, why we even have
the tree brought in as an altar or a
grove in our houses.
It's a hard one to get past.
Um,
So,
I hope can take it in, but not be too
overwhelmed by it. God just wants us to
know better and
and not
do as the pagans do.
We'll see that a little deeper.
So,
let's skip to the word Yule because
quite honestly, we've used it a few
times by now in the descriptions for the
other gods and so on.
So, in the Norse
the word Yule means wheel.
Now, this is a pretty big
connection that I have drawn for the sun
wheel or the pagan sun wheel, which the
Druids, say Satanists, and witches use.
That's where we derive our holidays
from.
And in ancient Chaldean or Babylonian,
the word Yule means infant or little
child.
Um we will see why.
In Old English, the word means jolly.
The concept of the Old Father Time and
Baby New Year have these same pagan
overtones as well.
Now, here's where it gets pretty um
dark.
So, go with me down below.
Yule
on the Satanic calendar very down
below on the page, it says December 22nd
was winter solstice or sab sabbat
festival or feast day.
This
is unfortunately the time which orgies
occurred, oral, anal, vaginal, and any
age, male or female, human or animal.
December 24th is called demon revels.
If you remember this from my other
coverings of the episodes on holidays,
it happens quite a few times in a year.
And this is when they um encounter
demons in their practices and rituals
and they do what's called dim war.
They have a high grand climax.
And um
it's just not good.
It requires any age, male or female,
human and or animal as well.
And then you have Christmas Eve, which
requires blood.
On Christmas, you would receive gifts of
body parts, usually from an infant male.
This is why we call it Yule.
This is why Yule means infant or little
child.
So,
that is the hardest and worst part of
this.
Yule was the name of the winter festival
that occurred in December and January
on the German lunar calendar.
In the 4th century, the church decided
to celebrate the birth of the Lord Jesus
Christ at the same time
with a 12-day feast often called
Epiphany
or the feast of the Nativity.
Um Pilgrim's Progress sounds like
abortion.
We're getting there, but there's
actually a holiday
time period that directly correlates
more or less with that.
And there's also a lot of other
practices associated with that today.
So,
um I won't be covering that in here.
But,
going back to the second sentence of the
paragraph, the first paragraph there,
it was a 12-day feast often called
Epiphany or the feast of the Nativity.
They planned the feast to correspond
with the pagan holiday,
which is the feast of Sol Invictus.
If you remember back when I mentioned
that before,
there you have it. And thank you so
much. Why are there 12 days of
Christmas? Well,
the 12 days of Sol Invictus.
Uh yes, and Saint G, that is very very
true that they do that.
Yeah, I just saw that the rabbis suck
the blood from the child during
circumcision.
Yeah.
Sorry. That is um side note, but
let's get back to the feast of Sol
Invictus, which celebrated the winter
solstice and gradually lengthened days
of increased sunlight.
Over time, these feasts merged to become
the holiday we know as Christmas.
In today's language, Yule is simply the
feast celebrating the birth of Christ.
Yuletide
is the Christmas season.
While many aspects of the story of
Jesus' birth are celebrated at the Yule
season, remnants of the original feasts
and celebrations also show up in many
Christmas carols and traditions.
The Yule log was a huge log that was
part of European Christmas celebrations
for centuries. The Yule log was lit on
Christmas Day and burned for the
following 12 days of Christmas.
A remainder of the Yule log was kept to
light the next year's log.
The Yule log was thought to be a have
the power to ward off misfortune.
So, it was kept in the home year-long.
Yule logs are now often symbolized by a
cake shaped like a log.
All right.
Let's continuing.
Let's make that full screen.
Within the Christian church
and that
they will actually
um specify what church that is.
No such festivals Christmas was ever
heard of till
the 3rd century.
And that not till the 4th century was
far advanced did it gain much
observance.
How then did the Romish church, so we
know it's the Roman church they're
talking about,
fix on December the 25th as Christmas
Day?
Why?
Thus, long before the 4th century and
long before the Christian era itself,
a festival was celebrated among the
heathens
at that precise time of the year in
honor of the birth of the son of the
Babylonian queen of heaven.
Again,
Queen of Heaven is mentioned many times
in the Bible not to worship her with her
cakes even. There's a
lots of cakes
for her.
As she transitions from Semiramis to
Astarte to Ashtoreth to Cybele
and many other goddesses throughout time
and history.
Sorry, getting back to what we were
saying.
The Queen of Heaven. And it may fairly
be presumed that in order to
conciliate the heathen
and to swell the number of the nominal
adherents of Christianity,
the same festival was adopted by the
Roman church.
Giving it only the name of Christ. This
tendency on the part of Christians to
meet paganism halfway was very early
developed and we find Tertullian even in
his day about the year
230 bitterly lamenting the inconsistency
of the disciples of Christ in this
respect.
In contrasting it with the strict
fidelity of the pagans to their own
superstitions.
By us, says he, who are strangers to
sabbaths
and new moons and festivals once
acceptable to God, the Saturnalia, the
feast of January,
the Brumalia and Matronalia. So, matron,
that means usually mother worship.
Are now frequented. Gifts are carried to
and fro. New Year's Day presents are
made with din.
I'm not sure what din means.
And sports and banquets are celebrated
with uproar.
Oh, how much more faithful are the
heathen to their religion who take
special care to adopt no solemnity from
the Christians. They never incorporate
things from the Christians. We only
incorporate things from them, it seems.
It's what he's saying.
Upright men strove to stem the tide, but
in spite of all their efforts, the
apostasy went on
till the church with the expectation of
a small remnant was submerged under
pagan superstition.
That Christmas was originally a pagan
festival is beyond all doubt.
The time of the year and the ceremonies
with which it is still celebrated prove
its origin.
In Egypt, the son of Isis, the Egyptian
title for the Queen of
Heaven, was born at this very time.
About the time of the winter solstice,
it's quoting.
The very name by which Christmas is
popularly known among ourselves, Yule
Day, proves at once its pagan and
Babylonian origins.
Yule is the Chaldean name for an infant
or little child.
And as the 25th of December
was called by our pagan Anglo-Saxon
ancestors
Yule Day
or the Child's Day
and the night that preceded it, Mother's
Night, long before they came in contact
with Christianity,
that sufficiently proves its real
character.
Far and wide in the realms of paganism
was that birthday observed. This
festival has been commonly believed to
have had only
its astronomical character referring
simply to the com-
completion of the sun sun's yearly
course.
Just a minute for a second. There we go.
So,
just Just we want to go back, let's
let's go ahead and read that again.
In December was called by our pagan
Anglo-Saxon ancestors Yule day or the
child's day and the night that preceded
it mother night
long before they came in contact with
Christianity. That sufficient That
sufficiently proves its real character.
Far and wide in the realms of paganism
was this birthday observed.
This festival has been commonly
to be of a new cycle. Oh goodness.
Mhm.
I guess that's the part that I really
thought was important.
But there is indubitable
indubitable evidence that the festival
in question had a much higher reference
than this.
That it commemorated not merely the
figurative birthday of the sun s u n
in the renewal of its course, but the
birthday of the grand deliverer.
Among the Sabeans of Arabia who regarded
the moon and not the sun as the visible
symbol of the favorite object object of
their
idolatry
the same period was observed as the
birth festival.
Thus we read in Stanley's Sabean
philosophy on the 24th of the 10th
month, that is December according to our
reckoning the Arabians celebrated the
birthday of the Lord.
That is the moon. So
I hate to say this, but when you look at
Islam and Muslims
start touching all these different
customs and traditions
what you have there is their worship of
the moon. That's why they like to have
the upside down moon and
Yeah, so he's right. They worship the
moon
um
the heavens when when talk God talks
about
astrology he means it.
So
we get all these things and we start
worshipping them. Why?
I don't I don't
I guess they're telling us why, but it
it's
crazy.
So
let's go further.
The Lord Moon was the great object of
Arabian worship and that Lord Moon
according to them was born on the 24th
of December. So this is according to
Arabians.
Which clearly shows that the birth which
they celebrated had no necessary
connection
with the course of the sun. It is worthy
of special note too that if Christmas
day among the ancient Saxons of the of
this island
was observed to celebrate the birth of
any Lord of the host of heaven the case
must have been precisely the same here
as it was in Arabia.
The Saxons as it is well known regarding
the sun as sorry regarded the sun as a
female divinity.
So here's the duality.
The duality that they mostly say is
there's a female side of the God and
there's a male just like Nimrod started
when he was Nimrod or Bale his wife or
mother that he actually married as his
wife
was Semiramis or called the moon
goddess.
And their child which is usually
represented as a star was Tammuz.
All right.
Getting back to that. So
they regard the sun Saxons do as a
female divinity and the moon as a male.
It must have been the birthday of the
Lord Moon and therefore and not of the
sun that was celebrated by them on the
25th of December.
Even as the birthday of the same Lord
Moon was observed by the Arabians on the
24th of December.
Wow.
So yes, good point. Baphomet is both
genders. You can see how Satan is always
masquerading with two genders and all
gods and goddesses
that are
incorrect and and not good.
Um
but this is just stating that
basically they have another form of
counterfeit false worship not to the
sun, but to the moon, but
it's all the same thing. Even if you
actually go
that's another topic actually for
another day.
But if you start looking at all of the
different um religions out there
especially some of the more specific
ones you will find
that yes, it's sun and moon worship, but
it's on different it's correlating on
somewhat of the same days.
Specifically with certain practices that
they hold and certain things they wear
and everything.
So I'll
probably have to cover that in another
time.
But
now this is something I am not
not sure if people realize, but there
are there is the practice of the
inverted Christmas tree
and there's significance to this.
The inverted Christmas tree has
historical roots in medieval symbolism
particularly in Eastern Europe where it
was hung upside down to represent the
Holy Trinity
and point towards heaven.
It also drew from the paradise tree in
medieval plays symbolizing the Garden of
Eden.
However, the cult symbolism associated
with the inverted tree
has also emerged particularly in modern
interpretations.
The inverted triangle is often linked to
dark mysticism
representing inversion or subversion.
Now listen.
Subversion of traditional values. So to
put it you know
to get rid of traditional values.
In the occult
an inverted tree can symbolize turning
established structures on their head
reflecting chaos, rebellion or rejection
of divine order.
These associations while not universally
acknowledged parallel the idea of
inversion and role reversal seen in
pagan festivals like Saturnalia
where social norms were deliberately
upended.
Thus while the original inverted tree
carries symbolic significance its modern
reinterpretations
sometimes embrace a cult or subversive
meanings.
The article is down below.
But um
just a note before we go into this
there was a little bit more information
just in case you're interested in um
a book called The Two Babylons. He
actually mentions more about this how
the tree
was not just called like the sacred tree
or the Christ Christmas tree. It was
actually called
the sex tree.
And he also mentions why mistletoe is
hung in and part of its
extended
sacredness according to the Druids.
And that might be important to some of
you. Um I found it very interesting. If
you want to read more there is Macola's
book as well.
Um if you go back to the other
slide that I had on Macola you might
find a book by him.
But the point here is that God many
people would say
God made the pine tree. Therefore it
can't be evil.
And so
unfortunately it doesn't work that way.
We we have a few examples that are
coming up here.
I'll go full screen.
Here we have the example of the
children, right? The children of Israel
turning to
worship a golden calf.
And it says
well, I should just say that we can't
take another
idol or God
and repurpose it to worship God.
It doesn't work that way.
So
let's just look at the verse. It says
take heed to thyself that thou be not
snared by following them after that they
be destroyed from before thee
and that thou acquire inquire not after
their gods saying how did these nations
serve their gods and even so will I do
likewise.
Thou shalt not do so unto the Lord thy
God for every abomination to the Lord
which he hateth
have they done unto their gods. For even
their sons and their daughters they have
burnt in the fire to their gods.
Yes
Yule meaning infant or child not only
were they kind of
cut into pieces and delivered as gifts
on Christmas.
But
the Yule log might have actually
represented burning your children in the
fire as well.
Now it's to today it's not so gruesome,
but it's not it's still not um
benign.
We have a Yule log cake that we eat
instead
instead of burning a log usually.
Anyway, continuing on to verse 20
sorry 32. What thing soever I command
you observe to do it. Thou shalt not add
there to nor diminish from it.
So
we are not to do as
the pagans do worshipping their gods.
Next it says
Cain brought Here's the idea that Cain
was doing the same. He was repurposing
and trying to worship God
in his own way
by bringing produce to sacrifice
instead of what God asked. God has
specific ways in which he wants us to
worship him. We can't repurpose
other ways of doing so or pagan ways of
doing so.
So it says
Cain brought of the fruit of the ground
an offering unto the Lord. And Abel he
also brought of the firstlings of his
flock and of the fat thereof.
And the Lord had respect unto Abel and
to his offering.
But unto Cain and to his offerings, he
had not respect.
So, God does not respect if you try to
take something else and make it a way to
worship him.
Um
and a
And Cain was very wroth and his
countenance fell. You know the story.
He was very upset that God did not
accept his offering of produce.
But, um that is the the takeaway from
this. We are not supposed to do as the
pagans do. Many people will make
excuses. I I saw it in the
um
what I just said, the
Israelites creating that
calf to worship and they said it was for
God.
You know, they said that they wanted
another God to worship while um
Moses was on the hill, they still said
it was a feast unto the Lord.
And then they you have
this example.
You just cannot repurpose it.
You cannot worship God in a way he tells
he tells you not to.
It's still pagan. So, you can't
repurpose where Christmas came from
and try to separate it from that, create
dissonance in you
so you don't know and think about it
anymore
and just do it just like anyone else is
doing. At least, if you really want to
worship God, you can't do that.
Um because he knows it's idolatry. He
knows it's paganism. And I
hate to say that because I grew up with
it, but
um once I became an adult, I saw through
it very quickly and I think it's
important It's a very important to God
not to worship idols
and other things.
And so, we must come to him and and
worship him as our Lord, not other
things
or other gods.
So, um
unfortunately
there are others that just kind of say,
"Hey, it's okay to do this. It helps our
churches. It kind of helps us, you know,
us
uh
invite people to Christmas stuff."
But
none of it
substantiates
idol worship that God talks about us
never participating in.
So, there's no excuse. There's no way we
can substantiate doing so in our life.
So, I hope this is helpful. I'm really
glad that you are all here. Thank you
for tuning in.
And um
just be blessed from this. Please go
with God and
let's make
God proud and make him the Lord of our
life by not worshipping other things and
putting
these holidays that worship other gods
in our life. You can go ahead if you are
really appreciating these um
presentations that we put together and
all the work we're doing with our
ministry, you can go ahead and give.
These are some of the avenues. Cash App
is candidtruthofficial.
You we have Venmo. We have Zelle. We
also um
if you go on our website
you have a donation page which shows you
even PayPal and several other options.
But
thank you so much for supporting us and
being
with us here.
Yeah. Have a good night.